41 seconds of logos you know what this
Disney Fox merger goes through there's a
good chance it's going to result in even
longer opening logo sequences with even
more logos per film and that's gonna
suck I don't know what you're thinking
oh no Falls in a cage how did this
happen
for Asian I met Hugh someone get this
skeleton an agent because it has
tremendous dramatic timing Oh son of
Odin holy SH that's Clancy Brown things
just got about a hundred times more
parallax up in this joint also this is
what happens when you open up your
superhero Cinematic Universe to aliens
gets wonky and cartoony in a hurry
just ask Steppenwolf who incidentally is
also a giant on fire alien monster I
cannot die
not until I fulfill my destiny and lay
waste to your own what I should be
destiny for him and everyone else he's
like an intergalactic air B&B nightmare
and you have seen Ragnarok the full of
Asgard Ragnar roll credits the great
prophecy prophecies also great
prophecies oh oh we'll burn this entire
opening scene is villain monologuing
done to the extreme not that you're off
your head and stashing away NASCAR's
fault right next to the thing this guy
wants needs to combine it with are you
crazy
hammer porn though I'd caution you not
to search a real porn website for Hammer
porn unless you like Smashbox and
improvised dildos why not start with
that when I wasted the 25 seconds
individually smashing enemies if you can
do this
did he just like level up or something
Wow for thoroughly beat Surtur's ass
here I'm wondering what was the point of
keeping Thor prisoner why not just kill
him wouldn't that probably be an
important step in fulfilling the
prophecy the certain aura that Thor will
make the right decision to put his horns
on the eternal flame later the Odin
charged hog-tie with negligence of duty
by he disappeared before the trial
goddamn scourge do you ever stop
expositing you were literally telling
those girls plot stuff before Thor
arrived and now you're telling him pot
stuff I'm supposed to announce you
arrived goth dude there is no point in
jogging to the city to arrive 10 minutes
after Thor like you've accomplished
something also note to Asgard invest in
intercoms and all radios or shorter
bridges I'm sorry about this thing with
the tesseract between this Eurotrip Jay
and Silent Bob strike back finding
Forrester and entourage I'm thinking
Matt Damon has a shot at the best
collection of cameos a war that doesn't
exist do me a favor look this way in the
vault so it doesn't turn into a giant
monster and destroy the whole planet the
one thing that can fulfill the prophecy
of Surtur changing into mecha godzilla
is kept in the only place where it can
cause harm this is like if you buried
parallax in the pet cemetery also planet
planet at the end of this thing we will
see your entire civilization as a city
floating through space on a jagged rock
it's a comet or an asteroid way before
it's a fucking planet the male and
female actors behind Thor here are
associate faking conversation so
important you would ignore the first
appearance by thorne years that I'm
wondering if they want a contest to
appear in this scene not one job just
the one that's true but also Thor can
fly which can't really be this guy's
fault damn it if you were worried about
Thor return to Asgard without you
knowing it you should have picked a
better hero leave it alive it's why in
general you can never take death
seriously in these movies big dramatic
death scenes turn into parody plays
starring Matt Damon and you don't have a
phone no I don't have a phone but you
could have sent a electronic letter it's
called an email while this banter is
pretty funny you've got to think Doctor
Strange has ways of communicating that
don't involve phones or emails look at
this place it's beautiful Wow Norway it
looks fake --is-- no I've stopped
Ragnarok I put an end to sir it's
already begun she's coming
Odin who is thousands of years old plays
the pronoun game so
the Thor has to ask who the hell she is
kind of suggests hello no sister
how does Odin have a daughter that he's
kept secret all this time and while he
admitted he screwed up by not telling
Thor about her and what she can do
this sounds more like the type of thing
where the character of Odin didn't know
about her either
until the script for this movie was
written couldn't stop it so I'm prisoner
isn't that virtually the same thing a
crazy universe we live in when someone
can imprison a person with magic but
can't stop that person with the same
magic I'm a different person now
yes you must face alone well thanks dad
you created this mess by your own
admission and then you waited until you
were this close to death to even tell us
about it goddamn space Catwoman is hot
okay so if Hellas power is drawn from
Asgard how is he able to do this on
earth Odin told us her powers would be
limitless on Asgard so how is this not
already limitless this not possible why
did Hemsworth decide to channel chatter
for this scene I have it on good
authority that this script started out
as Maleficent too and this is the only
thing that survived from the first draft
two mythical beings will now resort to
punching each other while flying through
a wormhole
that's what Einstein what a woman Moody
casually kills a couple of Thor's
buddies and it should be a lot more
meaningful to us because of what they
mean to Thor but it simply is a Thor
crash lands on a planet full of trash
and tell me this isn't the same place
where the Transformers found themselves
and the Transformers the movie we're
about to hear dare to be stupid during a
fight scene the player dragged a rock
somehow all this mrs. Thor
it's kind of crazy how little this movie
has to do with Ragnarok it's like a side
quest that you play in a Thor RPG if you
had the time when we last saw hell she
was at the Bifrost gate man had killed
two people
now she's deep into the city surrounded
by a giant army of Asgardians what
exactly transpired where she walked from
one end of the city to the other and
drew this kind of an audience without
the army trying to attack her
immediately I thought you'd be happy to
see me maybe give them I don't know any
kind of proof that you're actually
Odin's offspring and maybe they'll come
around
you just said some now you seem shocked
no one believed you what is even the
point here she defeated and banished
Thor and Loki with 10% of the effort
she's putting forth here dispatching the
generic Asgardian army can't she just do
something that doesn't make this movie
over two hours long the answer is Sekar
it's awfully nice for this planet to
have the infrastructure to put prisoners
through a virtual Epcot Center ride that
gives them all the details they need to
know about the planet they're on it is
the collection point for all
lost and unloved things not true because
I see neither my college Temple of the
dog CD nor my college self one of which
was lost and one of which was unloved so
the rumors are true every 20 years or so
Jeff Goldblum emerges from his
hibernation to feed mate appear in
movies and become a big deal for three
to four years before going back into the
ground in 20 more years he'll be in the
Avengers infinity Star Wars and be the
priest at the Han Solo Peter quill
wedding you don't need to be afraid
unless you're made of scissors see just
a little ruck papers as a joke for you
in space way out in space they still do
rock-paper-scissors I'll do another yeah
oh well I tried to start a revolution
but didn't print enough pamphlets so
hardly anyone turned up there's no one
been taught oh history you've been
banished for decades but you finally
come home expect the society that
banished you to have taught your story
to impressionable kids scourge somehow
avoids getting his head smashed in by
all that sealing that just crashed down
with the eternal flame you are reborn
that's exactly what this person who has
so much power she can take out an entire
army by herself needs an army also this
eternal flame has a ton of uses doesn't
it it's how certain will become a huge
Colossus when he puts his horns in it
and it can raise an army of the undead
it's one of those weird elements and
movies that do whatever you need it to
do at a moment's notice it's so useful
it makes you wonder why I hasn't been
used until now Oh green glowing army of
the Dead and cate blanchett but lord of
the rings similarity well this movie
think of next
[Music]
movie soundtrack briefly thinks it's
running underneath the Blade Runner
sequel the Grandmaster created this
place to be whatever he wanted to to be
so why did he create a world where the
sheet glitchy hologram exists Chris
Hemsworth is way way better looking than
me
[Music]
[Applause]
he's pretty funny isn't it yeah I took
it off this is - okay haha we all
remember what Hulk did to Loki in the
Avengers but he's been here for weeks
and he's in good standing with the
Grandmaster so how does he not know the
Hulk is here after weeks of being on
this planet he would have at least been
given the description of this guy right
Oh better I never thought I would say
this but I I'm happy to see you you've
definitely know better than to address
Hulk this banner or to think one can
influence the other all right this is
what we've been waiting for Hulk vs Thor
we haven't seen this ever except in the
first Avengers on the airship and Thor
had his hammer folks should probably
make quick work of Thor under those
circumstances since it was essentially a
draw the first time but probably not
over three minutes of marginally
thrilling no stakes gladiator fighting
between two Avengers basically space
Civil War on a smaller scale Civil War
sliders if you will I'm sorry is this
hammer supposed to have the power of
Thor's real hammer Hulk just threw Thor
like a tennis ball a second ago and now
with a random huge hammer Thor is able
to bat Hulk around like Bryce Harper in
a little league game well they finally
did it they turn Thor into Raiden
wouldn't the ability to shock Thor be
impossible at this point since he's got
the power of lightning at his fingertips
tell me about yourself scourge you see
we need to fill some time while Thor and
the others try to get off Sekhar I don't
have much of a character other than I'm
evil and want to rule the universe so
you need to fill in the gaps have a gun
slinger let me say feel welcome to Zion
how'd you arrive here
we're good that still doesn't answer the
question yeah the Quinn jet can be used
to fly in space but of all the places in
the universe Hulk could have flown that
Quinn jet the fact that he just happens
to be on this planet is 2009 JJ Abrams
Star Trek Spock cave level of
improbability where is the Quinjet now
showing where the Quinn jet is will
require a naked halt to simply point out
the window rather than just telling Thor
were to look behind all vision is super
convenient did we even know this was
possible that Heimdall could bring
someone to Asgard via vision this
doesn't work Frank
The Avengers simple four didn't see that
did you I don't know how this remote
worked so that it would release him from
the chakra thing the button he's
pressing here is no different from what
Valkyrie pressed to shock him earlier
and considering how this movie works I'm
surprised he's in shock himself for a
big laugh Point Break good thing this
ship is still totally functional after
being here on this joke planet for
nearly two years this is not what she
said in age of Ultron and that movie she
said the job was finished and absolutely
nothing about the whereabouts of Ultron
it's almost like this movie needed an
easy reference for which movie this was
from so they invented an alternate
recording just for the scene why does
this old miss it from Black Widow causes
transformation back to banner now but
didn't do so when she originally sent it
to you yeah about that how does banners
demeanors stay sufficiently angry even
during sleep to stay holed for two years
if you were to give me 12 hours I could
bring them both back to you alive I
could do in two what is this name that
tune just both go and try and do it
Jesus is there any reason only one of
them would get sent after Thor and Hulk
I just don't get Loki at all he has all
these illusions at his fingertips but
instead of using that he's like a guy
from death wish trying to rob Charles
Bronson I'm sorry must be very painful
memory Loki taps into the mind of
Valkyrie to see the trailer for Valkyrie
not to be confused with the Tom Cruise
tries to kill Hitler movie this is just
gorgeous
everything about this scene is rat would
you stop saying
thing I said out loud somehow comes out
of characters mouth at the same time
well isn't that the most convenient
appearance ever not only is Valkyrie
find a way to go to the exact place she
needed to be at this moment but the
beast that was about to hit Thor also
had a controlling device on his neck is
that a dragon fact more importantly are
those grapes kind of amazing that the
grand master allowed Valkyrie to
continue to have control over all these
prisoners after she sold them to him why
doesn't he have his own controlling
devices on them once the sale is
complete we are not doing get help
characters do the thing that they said
they wouldn't do immediately after
saying they wouldn't do it cliche I
should figure this out it's just another
spaceship well that was easy
that's right you can stand on top of a
spaceship that explodes not gonna hurt
at all and by some sort of magic you can
get thrown to another ship and grab it
by the seams as it hurtles through the
air how are all these ships missing
Valkyrie Mario jumps her way across the
bad guy ships to do some miracles and
it's super fun your PhD okay movie you
can't have it both ways
you can't wring comedy from banner
shouting about how hard it should be for
him to fly an alien spaceship then have
him fly it perfectly for the rest of the
movie
um no even the special effects think
this is bullshit
guys this movie has more utterances of
the word anus than most anal porn or
even most proctology lectures
well execution does she have any reason
to have kept him around
she hasn't relied on him for local
knowledge he's not any stronger than the
next Asgardian she can execute people
herself quite easily his character is
here so that he can have a change of
heart at the end but I can't think of a
single purpose he serves for hella other
than to stand and watch her listen while
she does and says expositional things
that we the audience need to learn
yeah the mountains heat signatures
people clustered together how is it so
easy for this ship to find the people
and thereby the Bifrost sword but the
god of death who flings daggers with her
brain and crushes magic hammers wasn't
able to find it until she threatened to
start beheading fools and someone told
her where it was wow she really did the
eyeball math on those doors perfectly
I'm not sure I understand Thor's
battle-plan here the last time he ran
into Hellas she started his hammer into
oblivion
he doesn't realize yet that he can
control his power without the hammer so
what's the plan yeah no one wanted to
see what happened next or anything how
in the did a slashing metallic weapon
caused that wound but no signs of damage
outside the eye
the wolf is immune to bullets because we
need a reason for banner who has been
useless as a character here to turn back
into the whole to know who I am this is
just plain awesome
even though Edward Norton did this in
the Incredible Hulk and it wasn't played
for laps I don't think I quite
understand how Bruce dying makes the
Hulk emerge but I think it's consistent
with what these movies are saying is
possible so I'm removing us into this
yeah no one wanted to see what happened
next anyway I'm the goddess of death
luckily this triggers Thor's Dumbledore
dreams so Odin can give him a message
from beyond the grave
or ether wherever Odin went that Hama
was to help you control your power to
focus it it's nevio source of strength
thanks dad you could have told me about
my power away before this literal ex
machina dream sequence but I realized
these revelations need to arrive and the
stupidest way possible our Scout is not
a place that was like Idaho so begins
one of the longest walks ever so that
the heroes can figure out how to fight
hello the truth about Ragnarok and the
very meaning of life before she arrives
long as God the more powerful she grows
hella has shown nothing but complete and
utterly infinite power since she first
showed up in this movie there isn't a
gauge for how much more power she can
attain she's shown zero weaknesses and
there isn't anything in her arsenal that
could be more effective this is never
about stopping Ragnarok this was about
causing Ragnarok well it's a good thing
you didn't take cinemasins advice and
take Surtur's crown light-years away
from this place but it's not like he
knew that then yes Loki's going to steal
this because Loki's got a Loki my
question is if he had free rein on
Asgard for as long as he did why hasn't
he already stolen this thing and used it
yeah good for you for finally doing the
right thing after all those times you
did the wrong and horrible thing almost
forgetting Karl Urban commando do you
really think it's a good idea to bring
me back to earth no especially since you
assholes already agreed it would be in
Loki's best interest to stay on Sekar
and you know Doctor Strange is going to
Chloe up once he arrives do you guys
forget everything in order to surface
the future plot because space is
apparently a one lane highway Thor's arc
runs into Thanos a ship on the way to
earth to infinity war and Beyond you
can't have a revolution without somebody
to overthrow so you're welcome and it's
a tie aren't you glad you waited through
ten minutes of credits to see that holy
crap so many revelations for the future
of Marvel there
man I am glad I prevented the ushers
from cleaning this movie for that ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes but the animal is
inside out and it exploded
[Music]
it's too strong without my hammer I
can't drink is bupkis I found it on a
cracker jack box
the Schwartz is a human star it's in you
I cannot die
not until I fulfill my destiny and lay
waste to you well is my hair out
yeah
[Music]
nigga skies